Today's topic.
Young woman says she's been ghosted eight times and has no idea why I feel like.
There's no reason why I shouldn't have a relationship.
I am the type of person that when someone shows me affection, I'm all in.
I like to text all the time. I like to just talk to them all the time.
The first question I always ask that's why.
<Laugh>, you're not wrong. Even the tone of voice. It's just, uh, <laugh>.
First question I always ask is, do you have a girlfriend?
Do you have a girlfriend? I met a guy. We had a great date. And then a week.
Later I went at this point. I don't even know what to say to you. Like it's,
it's get the clue. The common denominator is you.
S seminar named Brooklyn and we hit it off at dinner.
I felt like we had a connection.
So of course I asked the question that I always ask, do you have a girlfriend?
And he said, no.
You know,
what's the most problematic thing about this whole thing is how comfortable she
is at saying that question, which tells me that she's doing stuff way worse.
That she's not comfortable divulging. Yeah, but I'm doing that.
I'm I'm always doing the at so it's fine.
No, we talked a few more times and I asked him one more time.
Do you have a girlfriend? And he didn't answer,
but I followed up with another text that said, do you still want to go on.
The date that we played? I just want you guys to know what we hear.
When you say, do you have a girlfriend over? It's like, this is what we hear.
You're saying, do you have a girlfriend? And what we hear is, are you a liar?
Are you a liar? Are you a liar? Are you lying? Do you,
huh? And then we just keep hearing. I'm like, look, the type of.
I would be like, yeah, I do have a girlfriend. Are we done?
We finished PA had this funny joke where he is like,
this is a type of where I start hiding.
Just so I can blame her for it. <laugh>
you put in her purse. You doing your Robb,
the hell you doing with a whole Chandel that's my <laugh>.
That's what he said. So you go in and you're immediately off the first saying,
I suspect you may not have integrity because of whatever's happened to me in my
past or my hurt. It's like, who hurt you?
And most people think of themselves as people with integrity.
So when you keep questioning mine and I haven't done anything,
I get indignant about that because I'm like, yo,
this person calling me a liar and I haven't done anything.
And being falsely accused of something is one of the most infuriating thing.
When you are in a, what did I do to deserve this? Right? That's one.
And then I can't debate it. No, cause the more I try to debate it is like,
I'm why you being so defensive, right? Here's the thing. It's also ladies,
it's a dumb question to ask. If I'm a liar, I'm keep lying.
And if I don't have a girlfriend, all you're gonna do is push me away.
What is the point? It's like going to a scam artist and be like,
are you scamming me?
She's mad because she feels like she is a great catch.
And people are casting her way. She's being treated unfairly.
What she doesn't realize is that she's treating others unfairly.
She's like, like you want to be treated properly,
but you don't know how to treat others properly with respect. Hello mother.
Right? Where you claim, they ghosted you, you demonized them. De demonizing.
Demonizing is a strong word. So as ghosting, you see the hell out and nah,
I see what you did there. Exactly. Right? Ghosts and demons. I was trying to,
you know, stay biblical with this.
Why do you think it's a bad idea to come up to someone and ask them,
do they have a girlfriend? You know what? I think it's a legit question. Okay.
What I see here is the fact that you repeat it or repeat it repeats. Okay?
Let's say you ask me once. Do you have a girlfriend? And I say, no.
If you analyze some things and you see that there's some flaws in my character
that I'm lying, asking it over and over again on my side,
you just showing me that you don't trust me right from the start.
You just met me at this point.
And our relationship is gonna be based on the fact that you do not trust me.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> so I'm gonna drop that on your side.
If you just met that person, she said before, she gets attached really quickly.
And that's probably the problem because she meets the person.
She sees a future with that person. So she's gonna ask, Hey,
do you have a girlfriend? The guy says, no. Okay. He's a really good catch.
I really want to have that dude.
So that pause <laugh> that person is a really good catch.
I see my future with that person, blah, blah, blah,
then to reassure yourself because you wanna protect that future that you
saw in your head. You're gonna ask it again. That just makes you insecure.
If you're like that. If we just met,
I could just see how it's gonna be testable when we're gonna be together. Right?
You always gonna ask questions like four or five times.
Ain't no people want to be bothered with the same questions.
Four or five times when I already ask you.
So you get really attached really quickly, but she doesn't trust. Yeah.
You got trusted issue. Boo. Boo. Maybe when you was a kid,
people gave you too much, you know,
Cho chocolate chip cookies that ended up to be raising cookies.
You know what I mean? <laugh> trusted shoes. I definitely agree.
I've definitely had a raisin cookie before you, you thought it was,
but it's worse when you grow poor.
Cause when you finally get a access to a good snack and boo boo, no,
no poverty strikes again in the back of the face.
<laugh> the back of the face in the back of face.
Just feels like my mom's came out. Who told you? You get to have fun. Come on,
let me live. Can I live?
Can I have a little chocolate chip cookie raisins for you?
Think about what a raisin is. It's a great minus the juice. Oh,
let me get some juice.
<laugh> and then on the topic of like you going all in right away.
When you like somebody chill, it's like pump your brace, relax,
drive slow people that you're discovering should be like good books in that you
are only getting to read a couple chapters at the time.
Like you don't get to get the whole thing right away off the top.
And the resume's not gonna give you the whole book.
If you are too committed at the beginning of a relationship like that,
you're gonna sound crazy.
It's impossible to be committed when you just met someone,
you know,
the clingy thing just seems like you're trying to use somebody else to fill
whatever emotional void you got in your life. And so me seeing that dependency,
I'm like, I don't want to be that.
I don't want to be something you're addicted to because it feels cuz then I'm
like, Ugh, you got problems. And then I'm just here to shoulder them.
The other thing to consider is like, you're erasing me.
You're not seeking me for who I am. You haven't taken the time to discover me.
You're just loving me for this idea that I get to fulfill for you close to a
fit. Do you like me? Or you like being with somebody? Yeah.
Having a boyfriend. Is that what you that's different. So it's, it's different.
That's a turn off. I can see it. It's too much too fast. Let me discover it's.
So which is the ninth movie of fast and furious. Yes. Too much too fast.
That's but it's like you ever see in a trailer and it revealed the whole movie
and you mad cuz now you don't even wanna see the movie. It's the same thing.
Slow down. Pump your brakes, build the little tension drive slow. It's like
<laugh>, it's a good song too. It's a great song.
Met a guy. We had a great date.
And then a week later I went to his house and made him breakfast.
So I went upstairs to see his bathroom and I saw different types of shampoo.
One was for a woman and one was for a man and I got suspicious. I just said,
are you sure you don't have a girlfriend? He goes, no. I already told you that.
When I look over at his calendar and I see a girl's name on a Friday and it it's
circled. And when I left, I said, uh, are you sure you don't have a girlfriend?
<laugh> and then that's when he goes to me, I met a guy.
Boo, boo,
if you toxic and I choose to get away from you it's and that's not ghosting
that's me preserving myself. If I say to you,
I'm gonna go get a knife and stab you 10 times in 10 minutes.
And I leave with without explanation.
That's not ghosting that's me preserving myself. I don't owe you an explanation.
If you are being a terrible person, you are not owed that. Yeah,
because here's the thing.
People you also know are not interested in explanation.
Some people you'll tell I'm not interested and they want to drag the
conversation out for hours. Ooh, you stopped responding.
I still had more to say, boo, I'm done. I'm not your therapist.
I'm not here to sort out through your insecurities. That is your problem.
Some people use the word ghosting. I'm like, no ghosting is yo,
everything is fine. Everything going good.
We make a commitment for a specific date and I stop responding. Yeah.
But that's to you, what do you mean? I mean,
to the perspective of the person that is being ghosted,
everything is going well between you, between you. Yes.
But on the other perspective,
something came up or something is not going well. So there's that.
But do you see the difference between we're good,
but I'm going through something and you've been doing something that's been
hurting you. Yeah, of course. You know what I'm saying? Of course. So like,
what I'm trying to say is like,
if you've been hurting somebody mm-hmm <affirmative> maybe you don't know or
whatever and they start leave. That's not ghosting. You know what I'm saying?
Like if I beat you every day,
let's say I'm dating girl and I'm beating her all the time and she leaves I'm
like, she goes to beat. No, she escapes. <laugh> right. You see a difference.
Yeah. But if we're good and you just disappear with that explanation where I'm
actually old one, then that's ghosty. That's what you're saying.
That's a little distinction I make, I,
people always have these terms where they get to make themselves out to be the
victim. Well, oh, he ghost to this. Every time someone tells a story,
they're gonna make it out to be the hero.
If they lack self-awareness I've told stories where I up on this podcast.
Of course. Right. Like, so sometimes I recognize I'm in the wrong.
I've had to go to people and apologize. And like, what did you do? And I'm like,
you may not realize it, but that was messed up with me.
And I wanna apologize ahead cuz it's not right by my moral standards. Yeah.
So there's times where I know I'm the Villa. Yeah. It,
it takes a bunch of self-awareness sure. I mean I have as well,
you know what I mean? Yeah. But most people, when they're gonna tell the story,
they're gonna make themselves out the B2B hero. Sure. I agree with that.
So like what happened is that I went to McDonald's and then I didn't have the
proper change. So she's like, it's okay. We take credit, uh, excuse me.
I don't don't have credit the nerve of this girl. No,
you're the one that was involved. You know what I mean?
Like you are the problem. You're the problem. You're obviously the,
but they make themselves to be honest. Like,
can you believe the nerve of that person to be, but you, you know, that is,
that's two things. That's a, a lack of empathy and a lack of self-awareness.
Yep. Empathy. Because you can't put yourself in someone's else's shoes and,
and under stand their reasoning and lack of self-awareness.
You can't understand how up you are. <laugh> you up.
Some people like I'm such a good girlfriend. I can't believe I'm single.
I'm like, if you have to say, I can't believe it. If you have to state,
how much of a good catch you are, then you're not so much of a good catch.
All right. Let's just, uh,
we've only watched 52 seconds and we've been able to just dissect a lot of
things. There's a lot of anyways, whatever we.
Got built to help me figure out why I keep attracting men who are gonna ghost
me, who are lying and who have girlfriends,
because I'm done with the guys who are ghosting and I need a relationship.
Boom. We said it, oh girl, you need a relationship. Wow.
That, that hits you really bad.
I don't think there's anything wrong with needing to be with somebody.
I just think like the way she said it,
it sounded so like all my friends are married and I'm not I'm left back. Yeah.
There was like a disgusting desperation to it. <laugh> you know what I mean?
Yeah, absolutely. What? I mean, I saw it like I love water. I need water,
but I wouldn't be like, I need water. No, you're thirsty. Is he? I,
I need water. Everybody needs water. That's one thing I need some what?
I'm thirsty now. She's thirsty. There's a difference. There's a big difference.
But anyways, uh, is there anything else you wanna add on this topic? No, no, no.
I think we are good. You don't wanna watch the rest of the video? No, no.
I think we're good. I think, I think if you guys wanna watch it,
you can go find out Dr. Phil's channel. We just want to comment on that.
So leave your comments below. Let us know what you think. Uh,
do you have a girlfriend? Peace. Well, don't you take dad? I don't know.
Maybe
the fact that you're asking so many times
if he has a girlfriend,
don't you think that maybe just,
maybe that would have something to do with the fact that
they're ghosting you.
<laugh> that could be that ghosting you. You, you, you, you, you, you,
you, you, you.